willie circles the warning track now out
by right field and all the folks who are
up on top of the willy mays wall
on the arcade up there they get to wave
and applaud
bathed in the friday afternoon
sunshine easter bunny's record this year
two and one with a 2-0-0 era he's been
fantastic with 33 strikeouts
in 36 innings against nine walks you
take your bats against him you're going
to see a low to mid 90s fastball that he
can four and two save got a good
curveball a slider to change up three
balls two strikes to count
to grisham and here it is
he struck him out swinging with a high
fastball
the high hard one at 95 miles an hour
and it was up above the belt blake snell
on the mound for the padres 28 year old
making his seventh start
second consecutive start against these
giants
be the first time that he tows the slab
at oracle park plate with two on and two
out first pitch to longoria fastball he
swings hits it in the air deep to right
center field grisham going back and say
hey makes a running grab onto the track
in deep center so grisham tracks it down
longoria flies out
two and two and a curveball swung on and
missed strike three
first strike out of the night for blake
snell and a couple of quick outs here in
the bottom of the second inning
he wanted it down
it's away
but still
threw off his timing enough to get the
swing and miss two and two the pitch to
talkman is right down the middle and
strike three called a 96 mile an hour
fastball isn't it so refreshing to go up
to the guys that you know that can take
it and give them a hard time and they
just yes
right yeah and they can take it
swinging to miss elevates the fastball
at 95 and strikes out wilmer flores
third k for blake schnell two down
[Applause]
well up the ladder kuma change-up missed
the pitch prior and then this one out of
the hand looks really inviting 95 top of
the zone swinging a miss
number two here in the bottom of the
third inning
posey comes up for the second time
jose hits a high drive to right
it
is out of here
and it's two nothing giants
i have to tell you something
he does not hit many to that spot
but he does it with two outs here in the
third
and that my friends is home run number
eight
95 mile an hour challenge i mean right
over the middle of the plate
and posey has had a lot of power to this
side of the field and there's the gift
inside backspin 32 miles per hour watch
the carry
[Applause]
[Music]
and a strike three call on goria didn't
like it at all
that is strikeout number four for blake
snell but a two-run shot for posey it's
two-nothing san francisco here's hosmer
with one now nobody on
one pitch is hit hard the other way and
that is the first hit of this game for
the padres osmer sends one on the ground
into left field a well-struck single
against anthony de slofani and the padre
is a one out base runner for will myers
on the ground to dubai
to flores
to belt
double play
belt duvonne truckman
[Applause]
now the bases are loaded now if somebody
could ever just get a hit the giants
would have something here that three
base runners without a hit
into right field that's going to be a
base hit
here's the throw hole myers has got a
good arm cut off
longoria knocks it a pair it's four
nothing
how good has his opposite field getting
been
all
but you year you look through four
pitches all with movement away and he
just goes with it i mean that's that's a
big league of fat right there from an
experienced hitter and a veteran who's
in his 11th year
mateo
he is hitting here in the pitcher spot
to begin things in the sixth inning
grounder diving in third as longoria
gets up and his throw is off the mark
and mateo will reach
so nice diving play by longoria but then
he comes up throwing wildly to first
base
he knew he had to hurry with mateo
running
lead runner on here for the padres in
the sixth inning
fly ball headed to deep center field
back goes slater at the wall and a ball
is gone
trent grisham
with a two-run home run and the padres
cut the giants lead in half
fifth home run of the year for grisham
wanted the fastball up and in
didn't get it there and get on top of it
enough boy very short and quick sounded
good
tim stauffer note when was that 2-2
pitch line the other way and over
towards the corner over yastremski's
head and rattling around in fair
territory manny's on his way to second
base he'll get their standing with a
one-out double
so the padres who had almost nothing
going against east glafani in the first
five innings have homered and doubled
here in the sixth and now the tying run
is coming to the plate machado on second
one out two balls two strikes to eric
hosmer here's the pitch and that one is
hit really well deep to center field
slater going back again at the wall
looking up gonna go
the second two run homer in the inning
for the padres
grisham made it 4-2 and now hosmer ties
the game at four
there just simply isn't a guy up that
you want more at the plate than eric
hosmer right now
he has been the best padre with runners
in scoring position he continues that
for whatever reason
selman gets ahead of hosmer
and tries to get by by fastballs
four to four bottom of the seventh top
of the order for the giants against the
new pitcher the right-hander keoni kella
slater drives one to right
look it up
out of here
and the giants take the lead
home run number three for slater
greatest thing they ever did was close
up the right side of this park
it has opened up right field second time
tonight we've seen a right-hander
leave earth
and slater to 2-1 count olive buster
posey smacks it right over the wall for
slater home run number three and it
gives his team the lead
popped up
it's
hosmer who dropped it
so it'll be an air on hosmer
well you're talking about a gold glove
first baseman you're right he can't
believe it
and he winds up whiffing on him
before the game today
regardless to who was going to save this
game
line to right
you stream
reaches up and he makes the catch
extra bases written all over it it's
dead
one down yeah probably three bases
written all over it the giants had
cheated just over towards the gap in
right center but even at that he still
needed a good jump and a direct route
got him
that was perfect that's the pitch
that he hasn't had
and he could not throw a better one here
fourth pitch of the bat fourth fastball
and this is the one
got him
right at him with 95 on the payoff pitch
he gets a swing through see ya for his
second strikeout
got him
fastball up and in
mcgee gets the call from home plate
umpire bruce strechman and the giants
win
game one of this three-game series
in a battle that uh it's gonna be like
this
every time these two teams play absolute
male biter all the way down to the final
pitch